So the last time,
last lecture I ended with the Abrahamic
stories with the death of Sarah and that
was Abraham's wife.
And so we're going to
continue from from there.
Remember Abraham had a son,
Isaac,
and he was asked by God
to sacrifice his son,
which we talked about in some depth and
I was attempting to make the case that,
you know,
the idea of sacrifice
was one of human kinds,
great discoveries because it
meant the discovery of the future,
it essentially,
but it also meant the discovery that
the future was something that you could
make a bargain with and that
you could give up something now,
something impulsive,
some pleasure,
even a deep pleasure in the moment.
And you could strive and hypothetically
you could make a covenant,
a bargain with the future.
And if your sacrifices were acceptable
and that seemed to mean ethically
acceptable,
you had to sacrifice the right thing,
that that vastly increased the
probability that not only you would be
successful,
let's say,
but that your descendants would be too.
And I don't think that that's
an irrational proposition.
I mean you have to leave in it a bit
with the realization that sometimes you
know,
you get sliced off at
the knees no matter what,
right?
Because life has an arbitrary element
and and that can't be tossed out.
But building in the arbitrary element,
we'll say you still want to think,
well what's your best bat given
a certain amount of randomness.
And it seems to me that conscious self
aware sacrifice and proper ethical
striving is your best bet.
And you know,
there's another idea that I've always
explained it when I've explained it to
people.
I've always used the movie
Pinocchio as an example.
You know that when Japan was trying to
make his puppet into a self aware and
autonomous moral agent,
which is what he wants above all else,
you know,
he aims at the highest
good that he can conceive,
which is the star that he
prays to essentially and
hopes for the transformation.
And there's also something in that that's
unutterably profound and maybe that is
somewhat independent of the idea
that you have to believe in God.
I would also say that what it means to
believe in God in the Old Testament is by
no means clear.
And that's something I also
really want to talk about tonight.
It's not obvious what it means and well,
Japan know what he does,
at least is aim at the highest
good of which he can conceive.
You know,
and that that's actually been
a philosophical definition
of God upon occasion,
that God is the highest
good of which you conceive.
And
you know,
that's different than the
idea of a transcendent being.
Precisely.
But it's in line with,
it's inline with certain interesting
psychoanalytic speculations.
This is one of the things I
really liked about Carl Young.
You know.